comment ça va complète va très bien j'ai
oublié mais qui chez moi tu me connais
je suis un grand professionnel et s'en
méfie chez le papetier fille manon bon
on arrête
bah oui on arrête c'est complètement con
tu les a laissés au ski oui voilà sur un
tiers est que je ne nommerai pas j'ai
quelques tableaux tu veux les voir
oui la planète des singes
je ne sais pas qui a fait ça mais c'est
immonde et ignoble
et pourtant c'est toi tu irais je sais
mais pas toujours ça vous plaît ça vous
plaît
narry veulent paris veulent pas monras
main pour envoyer des toiles de 50 / 50
et des bonnes toiles bon là aussi c'est
pas ça c'est pas mal je l'aï pas mal ah
oui
de bananes
[Applaudissements]
là
ça fait trois ans on en a de moins en
moins mais bon continuer à envoyer les
toiles 50 par 50 pour mater une annonce
lundi au bataclan il ya une grande fête
avec malcom x et pour les quatre ans on
va pas célébrer les quatre ans de
détention d'ingrid betancourt mais c'est
à l'initiative de renault est plein
d'artistes ayant un spectacle il reste
quelques places avant donc allez-y je
serai moi même et ce sera une bonne
soirée une bonne action donc pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez-vous
il m'était impossible